let's get the going and let me start
with uh
with a fitting joke in this case which
uh
i think some of you may have
seen that about the front-end developer
and their knowledge
of sql why front-end developers eat
alone
or well because we don't know how to
join tables right
and i think this is very relevant uh
because indeed uh in the modern uh
technical community we have a huge huge
uh split of a different uh knowledge
uh right there are some people who
really know databases and sql language
pretty well and there are also some
uh the other developers which are
really writing applications those day
which may not
uh know the database technology
uh that well right including uh
the you know what is a join now if you
think about the most teams what i
commonly see
is is kind of a great split between the
developers
and the technical uh technical
operations
now if you think about uh uh operations
these are
folks which are focused on uh the
database
uh right uh something like dbas or
database architects or database
reliability engineer right the titles
have been evolved
or there are some generalists which are
also in charge of a data
database as a part of a whole like sisat
means site reliability engineers
and so on and so forth right we have
those kind of two
uh classes of people now if you look at
where
a lot of organizations especially large
ones we see there is
a lot of tension between the developers
and ops
right now if you uh
uh think about that there is a modern
concept well not super modern birthdays
right i mean it's uh
more than five years old called devops
which was
recognizing that and exactly focus on
bridging the gap
between devs and ops right in reality
we see not all the organizations
especially large one
really adopted that very well uh
especially
when it comes to the databases because
the databases
they kind of or its own often special
snowflake
compared to other parts of
of infrastructure right so for example
one of our approaches with
devops you think about where
continuous deployment then you know you
can
really deploy things quickly if you
break something you can
quickly fix it that is not how things
work with database especially large one
if you drop the table you didn't intend
to well
chances are it will take a time to
recover it from backup if you need to
run the alter table right to you know
add an
index or column to chances are that will
take significant
point of time right so the databases uh
still require a special
care even if organizations which are
having that devops
approach now what i think is uh even
more interesting
is if you look at the uh very large
operations you often have a operations
team
which is very silent as well right like
we may have
focus who are focused on storage and
network and particular operating system
right and
if certain things are not uh working
right they may be pointing thing
to everyone right and then there is also
uh security folks which can you know
establish
some uh additional uh roadblocks
uh be uh other security uh
rules or policies and so on
uh in the nutshell very often see the
developers thinking about
the database that can be explained this
simple way right from developer side
it is like the question of why this
stupid database
is always a problem why it's always stop
working then i'm not
doing anything wrong because from
development standpoint they
are if you don't understand how a
database works internally they're just
you know sending queries and one query
may not be different from an away from
their standpoint
but in reality changing you know some
scene
single clause from end to or may uh
make uh query thousand times more
complicated right and take thousand
times longer to complete
from operations people or and i mean in
this case the people who really
understand and care about the databases
uh
there is always a question about
developers why you do not learn the
database design
why do you create a tables with no
proper indexes
and then uh you know uh scream bleeding
bloody murder when things do not work
right why do not
write optimize queries right like go
through a process of assessing how
optimal query is before putting that in
production
why don't you think about the capacity
planning right again in a lot of um
in cases i see uh developers think
you know databases can magically handle
that right not really
assessing uh how much of workload
data queries uh it can happen and all
that
uh gets to their uh conflict now if you
look at
one thing i want you to take away from
this presentation before we go at the
practices for developers
is what if you look at successful
database operations right if you really
want to
build a large-scale successful database
part
application you need to understand what
database responsibility is a shared
responsibility
between devs and ops right and uh folks
need to
uh work that uh together right to
resolve the problem nothing else uh
really will will work okay
now without out of a way let's go
and talk about some of the talk
recommendations
i have for uh for developers
now the first thing is what you really
need to understand how a database works
at least on a high level uh on a high
level
right if you really think a database is
a black box and you're you know just
going to google and just copy paste
those create statements and some queries
you won't be able to
uh build the large scale applications
right maybe you will be able to
go by with some you know tiny demos but
it will
all uh crashing down sooner
sooner than you would hope right uh
because of all that uh complexity which
database entails
uh specifically you want to you want to
learn the schema design
the power of a database language such as
sql and in particular
how the database executes
the query at least in high level details
so here is
example of a database
relational schema right mysql
postgres oracle on a high level
uh it is a relational schema is the same
this is a
set of tables with relationships between
them
i think it is a very uh important to
be able to understand and represent your
schema
as a such set of
set of tables now if you look at the
query execution
i would encourage you to understand
query execution at least
on on this level this is how a query
executed
on mysql site from again very high level
point of view but this is
already very helpful because it uh
explains you for example what have
is a parser which which part has a query
there is something about optimizes for
query and combined with a query optimize
query execution plan which is uh later
when
executed right a lot of
developers uh imet they are
not really able to explain the database
operation uh database query execution
even on this very high level
uh the very important piece if you
really want to have
uh one thing you as developer need to
know
uh about a database is the explain
how query is executed right
and uh you need to uh have to know two
things about
explain a how your current query is uh
is executed and b how things will change
uh with your application changes right
because
typically the test query is in a test
environment with maybe some very small
data sets
and as database gets larger
then certain things
certain queries can become substantially
slower right which
actually if you analyze if you take a
careful look at
explain you often will be able to see
that this is a
visualized datagram which is from mysql
workbench
which has this fantastic query
visualization tool and then
also you can uh read about execution
plan
information and uh manual or
to i read explain better right i don't
have a time
uh specifically to go on into that uh
the postgresql
now obviously has uh has a similar
feature
right like in this case i am using the
tool
uh called to
uh pav right there is a link down there
which uh
shows uh uh
how you can visualize a plan right again
uh
very uh a very good tool
and both those visualization tools are
basically for
uh for convenience uh it is i think even
better
uh to get the skills to uh execute the
raw
textual output plan as a database uh
a database generates right then you
don't have to
ex rely on this additional level of
parsing from uh percona side
uh uh we are helping you to
understand the queries uh for
all the open source database we support
with our tool
called pmm percona monitoring and
management
which can show you what queries are
causing the load
on the system or you can also see
whatever slowest queries what queries
are causing temporary tables
uh and so on and so forth as well as
why you are causing this load where you
can take a look at
a specific query and understand uh
what is
what what is this
um uh the the what is the query uh taken
right
like in this case uh we can see uh for
example what
uh this query takes uh this coyote takes
only three percent of a query execution
time that means adding more memory or
getting faster disk is not going to
improve that query performance and also
how to optimize
this query performance which we do by
providing the most important
uh information about the query such as
uh
query example it's so you understand
what query you're optimizing
their query outputs explain output and
show create table for involved tables
right typically
using that information you are able to
uh understand how to optimize your query
so if you want to check out pmore
here is a demo pmmpercon.com where you
can
uh do a lot of uh
stuff without um you know check out a
lot of the features if i was installing
that
and also just yesterday we released the
new version of pm26 if you
uh want to check that out okay
moving on the next thing uh
which you need to understand about query
execution is how queries are
executed on a very high level right and
again
for some of them mysql all timers that's
maybe
look like a stupid question right a very
uh basic question but a lot of
new developers coming into the system
but now have a preconceived notions
they may uh not really expect
uh the behavior which many databases
have right think about that you have a
database cluster for example over five
nodes
which each has uh have you know
tens of cpu cores and if you throw the
complicated query on this cluster
as a reasonable person how would you
expect that to be executed
well probably you would
expect uh uh
that to be executed by using all the
resources which are
available on that uh cluster well
indeed that is how things work with some
of the database technologies like if you
think something
like hadoop or click house
indeed when you send the query in it can
use all cpu cores like all resources
on all the nodes which correspond to a
cluster
but that is not how mysql or postgres
works
the postgres actually has a parallel
query
um of features right that means
uh it can typically
use all the resources on the single node
right all the
uh all the cpu cores uh
uh right with uh some level of
of efficiency when you look at the mysql
though
it does not right and this and their
complicated
uh select queries or some
you know large scale update queries
either table they all
are executed essentially in a single
thread
you know a bound by the single cpu core
right which
is which is an important uh
limitation of that technology and as
you're building your application
you need to know that because what you
don't want to happen is you don't want
to be developing your
system on a single uh single node
let's say for cpu core system and
thinking oh you know what
it's no problem i can make my queries a
lot faster by
getting 64 node box and then finding out
what
now you don't because single query can
only run
on a single cpu core any technology you
that you have chosen indexes
the thing about the indexes is uh
indexes are absolutely critical when it
comes to
or to conventional uh
relational database right so you really
need
to make sure your performance critical
queries have
indexes they need at the same time
indexes are
expensive indexes slow things down
right slow things down then the query
cannot use those
those indexes now a lot of people
understand
what indexes slow down
queries uh update queries
right or uh modifications in cells
deletes because when i am
updating the data i potentially need to
update
all my indexes and the more indexes i
have the slower things are going to
become
right that is you know uh pretty clear
at the same time that also applies to
selects
because the more indexes you have the
more your data size will take so
possibly it will not have as good cache
a hit anymore and then uh
also uh
the optimizer will have to do a lot more
work
uh figuring out what indexes what
indexes to use
right so in the uh so do odd indexes but
do not
other indexes you do not need actually
uh this brings us to a very kind of
telltale style about
the bad indexes practices right there
are two if you give me
their database schema dump like mysql
dump
often i can very easily spot when
folks do not have proper indexing skills
in the team
the first one is if i
uh see pretty much only primary keys
created
in the system right that means people do
not understand indexes they created
primary keys because we had to or
because we have been
automatically created from them now the
second thing is
if i see almost every column
indexed right because some people
they take a very simplified approach to
index and we go to google
and in google they see well if you have
the column as a part of a where clause
i you should index that that is a that
is a bad idea
don't index all comma all columns and in
many cases you want to build the
multi-column indexes for better
performance not building indexes
separately on
all the different platforms
the next thing is capacity planning
uh no database really have uh unlimited
scale
right you always have to definitely
design for the lord
you have and this and also the
scalability
is a very uh application dependent now
what is interested in in this case is
you can tell
well there are some technologies
provided by the cloud vendors
being you know dynamodb or
google spanner cosmos db right which
promise
pretty much unlimited um scalability
well the thing we promise you is what
you run out of money faster than they
run out of
scalability resources right there is
actually some
design goals and those systems are not
unlimited in scale well frankly there is
a limit to the scale
of those cloud vendors scale right and
we actually have seen
what during the early days of uh
kovit pandemics many cloud vendors
experience the capacity limits
right because people try to who have
been
increasing the traffic have been trying
to uh
scale the instances and they couldn't
right
now another thing to understand is what
the scalability
is a very very uh application dependent
right it may not be just about the
database system but
in terms of how your application works
so for example
uh if you uh want to
you know control some of those cloud
vendors you can
ask somebody saying hey uh
does your database support million
updates a second
right and you probably would say oh sure
for google spanner cosmos db
whatever that is not a problem at all
right but then you can say well you know
what
i need all those updates to happen to
exactly the same row
right and then you probably say oops
that is not going to work
because serialized updates to the single
row
right they really have uh well
they really have a serialization problem
right which
uh introduces the scalability limits in
this case now
of course your application is unlikely
to be that application where all load is
just hitting
uh all updates on one row but it is also
probably is not going to that perfectly
scalable application
which vendors tend to use
as a showcase for how well they ignore
the scales so what you want to make sure
is you always take those promises with a
grain of salt
and do your own measurements right do
your own measurements in terms of
uh whatever extent of scalability of
systems for you
also pay attention to efficiency
right why is that important because if
you look at um at the
in the cloud space especially going to a
higher
instance uh size or larger number of
instances is a fair play in terms of
optimization
right it's kind of called tuned in by
the credit card in many cases
but that is something which can
really take you down a very wrong path
where
your application will be working and
maybe working with a good performance
but it will be
horrendously inefficient and that means
it will be
uh bad for your wallet and the
and bad for environment too you know
wasting all those
cpu cycles another thing
when you uh you need to know when you
talk about scaling
is this difference between a vertical
scaling
and horizontal scaling right these are
typically two
important approaches uh which we talk
about scaling data
data centers now if you think about
those approaches
the only one which takes you to extreme
scale is horizontal scaling
you cannot build a facebook scale
application for example by
uh buying a very large single server
there is not such a large
single server for sale but for many
small and medium scale applications
which are
majority by the numbers you can actually
uh
get by with a single powerful answer
instance often uh having your
uh architecture much more simple
and cost effective be because of that
right that's why scalability
uh and analysis and performance
uh and capacity planning is important
because maybe you don't need a
complexity for a scale you are targeting
for uh
a for sustainable future right uh
i think it's also good to point out
what uh uh the scalable and efficient
that
are uh kind of maybe often
seen by people as a similar terms but
they're very different
and in fact many systems
which you which focus extreme
scalability they are not very efficient
at that
because from software engineering
choices right it's extremely hard not
expo
impossible but extremely hard to build
the systems which
are very scalable and
very efficient at the same time
now uh another thing which i uh another
terms which i
hear people using inter chargeably is
the throw put in latency again this is a
very
uh important and different especially
for uh distributed systems
right like for example you may hear
something like oh
uh my storage can handle 10 000 ios a
second which sounds like fast
right but uh that well may happen with
uh let's say five millisecond latency
which uh means it will require
a lot of concurrent iops to achieve that
number and the five millisecond latency
uh
your storage will not be very fast from
a storage
uh from a user experience right uh again
uh understand the difference between uh
between
uh within those uh things
and uh test to understand what exactly
uh
you are uh here you're hearing right and
why this is important because in
marketing materials
you often would hear claims about throw
put
because throw put is
easier to reach than latency
right and especially predictable
low latency that is a a really hard
problem uh here's something which is uh
relatively unrelated to a topic of
presentation but i think that is a
fantastic picture
for many of us to uh to know is uh
the latency uh right or
or the timing for a different uh
operator
uh different operations and i think what
is especially cool is if you go to a
website they have a diagram
how those latencies have changed through
different years
so you can really see what not every
component is improving at the same speed
right at the same rate like for example
uh speed of light
is not getting any faster right so
a lot of things when uh transmitting
data
at distance concern uh we may be you
know
trimming a little bit of latency through
as it goes through some processing
hardware
but there is very little we can do in
terms of a
distance getting back to
specifically speed of light limitations
that is
uh where you really need to consider
that for hiv ability choices
because uh the holy grail
of hiv ability is to say well you know
what i want to have a system
where i have uh nodes in different
countries one in
let's say us either in europe a third in
south america right for example so it's
really reliable
right and then i want to make sure i
have my
rights and they're very fast as well
well it doesn't really work this way
right
you have to choose if you're using a
synchronous replication in this case
propagation will be delayed
or you will have to pay
uh for latency right it's uh
a one uh uh one of the two and in many
cases
what makes sense uh actually is to
build the cluster for example if in a
same region multiple availability zone
with synchronous replication
and then for disaster recovery use
asynchronous replication
to propagate data to some entirely
different
region in case the whole region
fails especially you need to understand
what a wide area network so networks
which
operate between different regions
different continents they
are different from your local networks
uh they tend not to be as
reliable especially when it comes to the
single packet delivery
right and you should expect increased
jitter means sometimes your latency
spikes
10 times when it's normal right for five
minutes and then go back to normal
or maybe you know things will go down
for 30 seconds and then recover
it's normal for wide area network but
it's
probably not for your local area
network and you need especially in the
data center level
and you need to make sure the system you
deploy
is uh ready for that uh another
thing which latency drives is what the
connections to the database are
expensive especially if you use a
ssl a tls and the query latency add-up
especially on the real network even in a
data center not
on your local laptop right where
uh there is almost no latency going from
your
uh you know node.js to your database
server right right in
in the same place right query latency
that is something which uh uh as example
i have seen some developers they have
extremely high number of queries because
they just don't
want to learn sql features right i have
seen people instead of having one query
with maybe a couple of joins
to fetch uh the table they would
essentially have
series of queries for every single cell
of a table uh we're drawing creating
tens of thousands of queries for a
single page view
right very bad practice very inefficient
uh a lot of loading database uh high
latency and so on and so forth
now uh many uh frameworks those days
they are using the orm
called like or object relational mapping
and some people
hate orem some people absolutely love
them
right in reality it is a fantastic tool
in terms of its allowing developers to
create a database without need to
understand sql but it also can create
sql which is horrifically inefficient
what is important here is what you want
to learn
uh your framework many of them support
hints to help
the sql generation and also
be ready to mind you write sql if there
is no
choice there are questions even the most
modern best rm framework where screw up
and going to have a horrible horrible
sql your database
uh will not be able to handle well
guess what if it can't handle it won't
uh
it won't fly you just need to get rid of
that sql and rewrite that manually right
or
uh tune your or m framework for the uh
doing that
uh another little tip
do not leave transactions open because
uh
open transactions are very expensive uh
you know bad for database can
introduce a lot of bad bad side effects
so
make sure to always
close transaction right when you are
interacting with uh with user
another thing uh i think which is very
good to understand for developers is
understanding what every database like
actually every system has an optimal
concurrency
right what that means is uh
if you uh let's say
create certain amount of threads and use
a database from
all those threads it will uh perform at
the
optimal level if you create much more
threads
you know go to thousands of ten
thousands of threads
then performance actually will go down
because
all that effort which is needed to
coordinate those threads synchronize
them and so on and so forth right
uh that is uh the consequence of uh
uh gunther's universal scalability law
uh decided here and uh you better to
have idea at least in a higher level
what is that optimal concurrency for
your database
typically it's going to be tense or
maybe hundreds or maybe 100 right of
of active uh queries going on at the
same time
it's not going to be thousands now how
do you
deal with that how do you keep your
database operating
in a level well you want to make sure
what you
embrace q in that means what you are
not sending the quest to their
not sending all requests to a database
but
uh maintaining their optimal uh
concurrency
in some uh some case sometimes the
queuing can be done from
uh you know normal queue sometimes the
queuing kind of magically happens when
you're using
the connection pooling right so for
example if i am
uh developing in java and i limit my
connection
poll to i don't know let's say 64 uh or
128 if i have a spike of a load and i
need
thousands of database connections well i
can actually wait for a connection to
become available from a pool
right and limit that load
in this way or i can use tools like
a proxy sql uh uh
to do that finally in uh
a software such as percona server or
mysql
enterprise there is uh
their uh fred pool functionality built
in when you can
i can essentially do that uh connection
pulling on the
on the database uh no on a database size
if you think about proxy sql and other
database
technologies whereas uh also similar
technologies exist like
uh uh postgresql has tools like pg pool
pg bound bouncer uh uh audisay right and
uh a few hours in general all those
practices
uh i would sum up like uh like this
right i would say their
uh law of a gravity as it applies to
application developer
where sheet application at scale will
bring down
any database right the best tuned the
most expensive
open source commercial uh doesn't matter
that is the universal law of
gravity okay
a few more tips scale
matters right what you want to make sure
is what if you're developing and testing
the toy database
you're probably not knowing how query is
going to perform in many cases it's very
convenient right you can do it
very quickly you know reload the
database if you need and so on and so
forth right
but make sure you don't go from toy
database to production make sure you
have some staging database or whatever
which has a data set which is a
similar size and similar kind of
relationship as a production database
you expect right
especially this is important because
slowest queries
may slow down most rapidly right and you
may see
some of your bad queries to become 1000
times slower when you increase your data
size
only by 10 times memory disk
that is related issue right if data is
in memory it's much faster
even then they're speaking about modern
ssds so
if you are having a small data set which
fits in memory on a test box and then
you go into much
larger data set which is additionally
doesn't fit in memory and require this
ko
performance difference can will be
multiplied because of that
newer is not uh always faster
right upgrading to new software and
hardware
uh does not always uh give you
performance uh
uh benefit so make sure to test it out
in certain cases
defaults are to blame like for example
some of the new linux kernels have
became more secure by default
right in terms of all those you know
security
issues processors support over the last
couple of years
but me also made them
made them slow right and uh
defaults uh those are often to blame so
make sure you
uh you test you test it out
right now the upgrades when it comes to
the databases
uh this is where you store your data so
t uh so
running the database which is uh out of
uh past end of life and often not an
option because of uh
security risks right because there may
be some security holes found
and there is no patch coming out for
for something like mysql51 right or
postgresql8 at the same time the major
upgrades
often uh require application changes
so make sure to be uh
to be ready for that and plan in the
life cycle of your application team to
support with database upgrades after
uh after applications stop maybe being
developed
developed actively right
character sets that is another
interesting thing because it has a huge
performance impact
it's also pain to change after you set
it and also
if you have a wrong character set or
characters that mix
match between your application uh and
um and database
uh right then um
that can cause uh their
uh the uh because uh
they can cause their data loss
right uh here is uh also an interesting
uh thing for mysql in this case about
the
uh impact of a character set performance
and you could see
in a mysql five seven actually going
from latin one to utf-8
had a quite uh uh different uh
different performance in mysql eight
a lot of ad performance gap was uh uh
was closed
and mysql 80 actually has utf-8
by by default
right why point this out is relating to
a change in default
some people do complain about
mysql8 performance in benchmarks
but they don't recognize that mysql8 has
a different default for character set
actually much better one because
so much application use smiles those
days right and so on and so forth which
are only represented well in utf-8
character set
another thing to uh to consider is the
operational overhead in many cases when
you speak about capacity planning or
time
which is needed it's uh all focused
about the normal or database operations
but if you think about where things like
uh
the you know the large-scale database uh
backups
or upgrade even adding the table they
take time it costs money it
introduces additional overhead venetrans
and you need to make sure there is
enough scale capacity to do that i have
seen so many people
saying well you know what we can't
actually run back up on our database
well because when you run backup our
application team tips over well that is
not a good capacity planning practice
when you can't really
can't really run backup
on the automation now automation is
something which is
interesting right from one extent it's
of course is absolutely a must right we
are not able just to manually install
and manage the database anymore because
uh
many uh of us have to manage way too
many databases
right this way so aftermation is
critical at the same time
that means what the mistakes and
affirmation can really destroy databases
scale
i have seen so many people running the
script let's say
on production instead of test
accidentally
and ruining the database on hundreds of
instances
right what you need to do to avoid
this is you want to make sure what there
is a lot of testing done for your
automation framework and practice which
prevent you from running
the scripts in development production
some first proxies are pretty simple
like for example do not use the same
uh passwords for development in
production that means
even if you accidentally point your
script in their own way well
it's uh it will fail right
and and also make sure you qa
do code reviews right and so on on your
automation pro
framework because it is uh needs to be
absolutely solid
uh then uh uh we're finishing up with
our
security right the databases is where
your most the sensitive data tends to
leave right i think that is um
pretty obvious and uh taking care of
that data is a shared responsibility of
devs and ops
in so many times i've seen developer
thinking well database security is
ops responsibility they change password
we paste it
uh we patch it and so on and so forth
right but that doesn't quite work with
for example sql injections and other
bugs
which come with uh
with buggy applications they cannot be
uh efficiently solved by ops people
right
you need to have a make sure that
security conversation
is had and devs and ops are working
working together to to resolve it okay
uh with that i also had a couple of uh
announcements to make now if you really
want uh to learn more about the
databases
uh vietnam also taken our conference
online
next week as per corner live online and
that will be
the single track 24 hour around the
world uh
event so we're doing a little bit
different format but uh
i think that's going to be a lot of fun
so uh
check it out and register if you like we
have
speakers from a lot of the very uh
very cool uh company right and we'll
also share some
uh new developments in vapor corner
software
and also i have a little favor uh to ask
we are doing the open source database
survey right
we really want to know uh how you is
using the open source database so we can
help you
will help us to serve you better uh to
be more focused on our software
development
and also we are going to share all the
results uh
under creative commons license right so
there is a link
uh yeah i think you have like a five
minutes before
closing keynotes if you or open it up on
the side and complete right now
i would not mind
and if that's with that i had a
comment a question from debbie yes i
think a point here on whether it's
postgres
or other uh databases
it did the old version they tend to have
a very
high stability and maturity uh but uh
sooner or later they are not going to be
uh getting uh bug fixes right even
security by uh
security bug fixes and that that means
if something something change
changes that becomes uh
problematic right having said that i
think uh
there is a lot of postgresql mysql
replication which
applications which have been you know
working fine
on the database which is like 10 years
old so
old plus right we just uh
i don't have to follow that security
compliance practices right or just have
been lucky
okay well so nancy what a
protocol i think i'm pretty much out of
time here there is a few minutes for you
to
transition to their uh
closing remarks at 4 50
eastern okay thank you nick i am
glad you all liked the talk
thank michael tina and
so many so many
uh others oh
yeah thank you abdel for acknowledging
the problem on same
password and development and production
that's really
takes guts to do it in public
okay well thank you everyone
i'll stop sharing this point